ていきます
つい
っていう
まあ
5 re
ん
goo
今日はドクター
はじめです皆久しぶりですドクターはじめ
です私今まで様々な角をやってきましたが
この3億円の号前に住んでから未だ強くて
シンクがこうれるの怖くてなかなかほ爆発
的なやばい実験ができてなかったんです
けども今回もこのを打つの一発目の実験に
ふさわしいとも実験を早速やっていきたい
と思うんですけれどもああああああ
持ってそれじゃあこういうので今回ぺ
シャルゲストをお呼びしておりますどうぞ
お願いしまーす胃腸科元気で推せ授業
よろしくお願いしまーすお願いますあの昔
国のお家の地下でやったんですけど増の
歯磨き粉の実験あ一瞬で泡が出るそうです
ねある地下で行ったところ
[音楽]
ええええええ
大大惨事になってしまったんですよあれ
どれくれ良好なんですかねありましたけど
束の20リットルくらいのお母さんが水素
を使ってましたね20リットルくらい
それ
阿蘇へ
それ先生
戦争へ家の裏にも遠出できませんかねあー
できますけど今出たらこんなんだっけ
ちょっというとチョコってなんじゃいます
20 l クーラー
じゃ前世
速攻大とと言わの20人を取るから増量
することとか出てきたりしませんかねそう
ですねぇ結構危険な薬品なんであそうです
よねそうね用意
どうなるかわからないですけど
僕なら大丈夫ほんとですねありがとう
ございます3億円の方でのすごいところ
ですね大きなに刃が付いているところに
あると思うんですこれはもうせしてゾーン
の犯人が引越すると言わんばかりの空間が
ありましている確か広いそこでて今日は
ですねぜひタンク園の豪邸の一発目のおは
に厚的実験はゾーンの歯磨き攻特打サイズ
でやりたいと思いますよやりましょう
ありがとうございますどの位の量いきます
かどれくらい行けますかもうあの中には
はみ出すくらいやっちゃいましょうか
そうですねハミィフェスが入っちゃい
ましょう駐車場な100倍くらいじゃ
ましょうね
ですよね
大丈夫ですが安全に寄与間ですね周囲ね気
をつけなきゃですねはいそれに容量的に正
も全開なの部屋の最低20リットルだった
と思うんですけど
今回どれくらいまでにチェックですから
ですねまああの100リットルくらいは
普通にできる大
ソッキュが広い
そうですね始めた普通のユーチューバー
じゃないああもちろんですがもみあげ
ございますトップですよねなんであの日本
でもトップクラスのやったことないでよ
200リットルぐらいですか
10倍
やりましょう
もうどれくらい入ってません部営繕便です
かはい招集しています
これを言っ k 10 k 10 k
いいですかはいこれ1本5000円します
かえーるソフトガンがせず売ってる感じ
たらべ
[音楽]
えっ
やりますか
みましょういやあこうやってきたなぁと
いうわけで激戦で準備が整いましたという
ことではい早速やっていきましょうやって
みましょう前回と同じくバスターる準備し
ました応募いスポーツ大きさ的にはどう
ですかああいい
じゃあ攻めれるめっちゃ滑れるフェアの
泡沫であろうあっつに行くのだけ強いんで
そう一羽のチーズだよ二人準備させて
いただきましたはいザイールできますまず
かねないよ一応世界の頃からかねないよう
にならないよ
ってどうでしょういいですねぇ
強いを時期薬使ってますからいます
有馬さんあり
10本やりましょうズっぽいれます
ねぇ
みなさんそろそろね space for
ね
アーマー女躍進これをさやばいですね
このあの先生が言うとラバ飯よりヤバいん
だろうぜん
うんもなかなか先生もこの料は使わない
ですかものは良までやったことないですね
過去県別に虫がいますあそうですね一瞬で
今日の宿10バーディあると思この日本の
無駄にと全部閉めてしまったそうすね前で
生活できる
oe 柄なんかも言えるジェルしています
アーサーずですボブやるぞ
えっ
えっいやは行ってとかこれ
今日もすればいいんですよね過酸化水素が
ね大量に入りましたねはい今ねぇもう
[音楽]
はいロッテもぐらいのある船の糧になっ
ちゃってますけど n を入れているって
いうかいいねねえよってほしいよだいぶ
濃い分日になったら
いい感じだと思います
ここにその後レフのいい散歩いう発生機
だって雨にならないですね先生入り
ましょう潜在れますまじますねはいやを
立てないようにね夫まで打つ
[音楽]
寄付
聞いてきせめてあついあついする場
めっちゃくれるとこなんですよさすが暑い
と反応やばいんですよ
うん
そういう
あの温度が高いと反応が速くて握る下が
ない先生
いっぱいいっぱいですねお風呂ですねここ
に足さなきゃいけないからねアプリを選ん
でくださいこれこれでいきます
皇帝初の
消去大の実験
そして
1000万人向けてるの
気合も声で200リットルと増の潘恵子
いくらああああ
[音楽]
てい
本
じゃあ行きますよ
皆さん
ています
水
ファンっ
て
うん
ん
うんうん
あああああああってもらったふう方は
なかった
あっはーん too
ん
[音楽]
voodooねちょうどいい量です後か
肌着末でよかったん
ちょうどいい量が何かもわからんでもう
ちょっと萌えるだいじょ
かざの構え
ん
ぷっ
この兄はの hiro さんの何かあり
ましれましたねもうちょっといけるんだ
みたいにそうですねもっと深いバスタブ
いけるんだっていうのがね
そうですよね夏木は300ビットでお会い
しましょう